foreign
magazines that exist to disseminate
scientific findings to the public such
as is Natural History still in existence
or did it disappear it used to be a
great magazine and then it went nuts
even before everyone else went nuts or
it went uninterested as far as I know
it's still okay well Natural History
discover Scientific American these are
Omni it's not
him yeah that was that would never as
much in my in my world but those those
first three like we got those in my
house when I was growing up
uh and they were you know they were
understood to be the ways that
scientifically interested people uh can
keep up on scientific findings either
outside of their own fields of their
scientists or outside of you know or
they're not scientists but they're
scientifically capable and interested in
literate and want to want to know what's
what's what yeah it was the popular
presentation of actual
scientific discovery exactly and there
you know there was there was some
controversial stuff and there were
things that you know you might disagree
with because that's the way science
Works uh and
um and there are also interpretations of
things you know whether or not the
finding
um turns out to be true or not the
interpretation of it uh May separately
uh not not be the right interpretation
um but Scientific American has I mean
long since jumped all the sharks it
feels like not that that's a thing uh
but here
here we have uh here I'll put up their
tweet before actually yeah you can you
can just put this this is again I picked
this up from Twitter where I quote tweet
Scientific American and what Scientific
American has said is this
before the late 18th century hopefully
that's not playing
before the late 18th century Western
science recognized only one sex the male
and considered the female body an
inferior version of it the shift
historians call the two sucks model
served mainly to reinforce gender and
racial divisions by tying social status
to the body
true facts about the male
so what what I said in response which is
so it's an understatement we're in a
scientific publication forgets that
reality exists whether or not humans
perceive it accurately
the idea that because
that because science didn't understand
everything about the universe at some
point
there must not have been a reality then
and our confusion now can take
precedence and we can use confusion from
earlier to cement confusions now is
truly backwards and like I just I keep
on coming back to the Fermi Paradox and
thinking like this is it this is this is
the kind of society ending confusion
that keeps us from ending up making
contact with other conscious beings in
the universe because if this then
there's there's no amazing space
exploration for us like we can't do it
we can't do it if we think these things
right
um yes the colonizing of other planets
will be much more difficult if we have
not at least ensured that people from
the two actual genuine Sexes who are
still of reproductive age have arrived
in these places capable of producing
Offspring
um yeah but I would just point out that
even you know
who amongst us does not in their own
mind have
Rock Solid evidence that people have
been aware of the sexual binary for
two plus thousand years right two plus
thousand wow okay well I'm just saying
if the idea that this was discovered in
the 1880s 18 somethings I don't know
let's make it the 1880s something okay
like the 1880s right the average person
knows that
the Old Testament for example contains a
certain number of references to the two
Sexes suggesting that people
that far back already had become aware
of this this binary yeah right so how is
it that scientific America and really I
think we need a new category because the
purpose there is not to convince anybody
of this nor is this the product of
anything that even rides us to the level
of a confusion right the purpose of this
is if you wish
to deny the absolutely obvious and
incontrovertible fact of two human sexes
then you're going to need something to
work with in other words there comes the
point in the conversation where you wish
to assert that there are not two Sexes
and the person on the other side of the
argument says hopefully in a respectful
way you're completely full of [ __ ] and
then you need to say the next thing
right about why you're not full of [ __ ]
and so the purpose of this is to have
that next thing in hand and to have it
come from a respectable place like
Scientific American because then the
person who has called you out for your
garbage thinking is then back on their
heels they may not have a next thing in
which case you win and there are no
longer two sexes
that's right because that's how reality
Works guys that is how reality that's
how reality works and that's why we'll
never meet Aliens wait wait
that is how reality has always worked
now I need Scientific American to give
me the peace that I say when you call me
out for being full of [ __ ] I'm sure
they're coming with it well no doubt I'm
sure they will so actually
this strikes me it hadn't occurred to me
before um but during your your brief
tirade there I thought about quarties
and so quatis c-o-a-t-i
um also known as quarter Mondays are a
neotropical that is to say uh the
tropics in the new world in the Americas
procyonid which is relative of the
raccoon they are they're gorgeous
they're snouty and they're brown and
they've got some Stripes further back
not as stripy as the raccoon no
um more Brown they're um they're forest
dwellers
um they climb okay like raccoons climb
okay and they just they're they're quite
lovely that I think the first time we
run into them and you've actually got a
picture of me sitting next to one and
was in Monteverde in uh in Costa Rica in
the cloud forest on the first summer
that we spent backpacking through
Central America it was near the end of
our trip
um but what we heard I believe on that
trip for the first time uh and we've
heard it since although because I hadn't
occurred to me I have not gone back and
looked into the research here what we
heard then was that when researchers
first when Western researchers were
first under discovering the quota Monday
the quantumundi presumably having long
since discovered itself as the original
human inhabitants of these forests
having monsters discovered them but when
Western science came in and was like aha
I have found it Eureka the quarter
Monday it won't exist until it has a
Latin name it won't exist until it has a
Latin name such as the nature of science
and reality apparently but now when the
quarter Monday was discovered I don't
know this is maybe in the 1880s
um you know early 20th Century mid-20th
Century something
uh it was thought that there were two
species because one of them uh which was
I don't remember but I'm gonna guess
maybe a little bit larger body was
always seen
um singly and it was like oh wait did
you see it that was a I think that was
maybe called the quati that was the
quality and then there were these like
Aggregates there were these ones they
always had little ones with them and
they had a lot of bigger ones and they
were called the mundies I guess
I guess and as it turns out the mundies
were the females with their babies and
they were social because often females
with babies are and the quatis uh were
the males that were solitary it's a
poligenous mating system and it all fits
together now that we have a better
understanding of mating systems and
biology and no that doesn't change the
underlying reality about what qualities
or Quantum undies are and it does mean
that science got it wrong science got it
wrong and then through an experiment in
which they checked the junk of these
Pilates and Quantum undies they
discovered it's being raccoon relatives
was not too easy it was a task yeah it
was a it was a they got scratched up no
doubt but um yeah and boy the NSF grant
for that junk checking inquadius I think
it had a different title but anyway it's
not the only story of this kind in fact
the elephant seal went through the same
thing
um so there are two species of elephant
seal and I forget which one it was but
the the thing is that morphologically
elephant seals are so different males
and females are so different in size and
also facial structure the males uh even
uglier than the females which if you've
ever seen a female elephant seal you
might find difficult to believe but now
take a look at a male even uglier yeah a
lot of a lot of uh resonance bulbous
nasal stuff going on but anyway they
were understood to be different species
until again a junk checking experiment
uh revealed the truth I want to know
what division of NSF that is like where
you apply for the NSF grant for children
right next door to Naval gazing oh yeah
yeah um okay yeah and it's these
departments are expanding they're taking
over yeah apparently taking over the
whole NSF
[Music]